[Music]
ha no you took just Laos in my France
this is guns in here welcome to my 50th
episode of dirty chess tricks now in
spite of having knowledge of many tricks
and traps recently I fall for one of the
high profile trick and not to my
surprise when I checked later on in the
database I found out that there are very
few games played with this line so in a
nutshell you can use this line as a
complete surprise weapon in the two
Naumann practice the opening arises
after the following model E 4 D 5 e
captures defy Queen captures defy Knight
to c3 attacking the Queen Queen to a5
and now the main move over here is d4
but as you go on you will see that my
opponent completely avoid that more here
you can continue it either of those two
moves let's say in the game he continued
with Knight to f3 and after the main
line continuation Knight to f6 Bishop to
c4 it is very natural for any black
Scandinavian player that he wants to
take this bishop out before he closed
down the pawn chain ok Bishop to a5 so
now I am all set to create my little
center with a 6 and c6 and accordingly
white still delay the movement of the D
pawn and castle on the Kings side well I
respond with a 6 and after rook to even
here comes the most critical position
where if black continue with the new
response c6 which looks very obvious as
white is threatening the move rook to e5
in fact turn out as a big time disaster
for the black camp let's see what is
wrong with this obvious move as it gives
the escape square to the black queen but
in fact after rook to e5 it doesn't
matter wherever Queen moves
white next move is very obvious yup you
guessed it from the title rook captures
fi a wonderful exchange sac which
completely ruined down black all hopes
in the opening stage here black has
three of your choices and let's see each
by turn how disasters black position can
become in each of this variation the
first move I want to consider is Queen
to c7 which in fact I played in the game
and as soon as my opponent played the
obvious move rook captures fi I was
completely shocked shocked as I have
never seen such an exchange sacrifice in
the opening stage okay
black has no choice he has to recapture
the rook and now comes the whole point
behind this exchange sacrifice as White
has this lethal reply Knight to g5
hahaha and suddenly to my horror I find
out that there is actually no defense on
f7 Square
now even though I lost badly in this
game I like to show you how quickly
white can rip apart the black camp as I
continue with this small tactic Knight
to g4
so if white continue with the foolish
move Knight captures f7 then I can
create some problem with Quintus to
check well my 2200 rated opponent is a
very smart guy and obviously he didn't
fall for this
and he choose the wise approach first
Queen to e2 check and black can choose
three worst option to lose the game
first King to d7 is a vast know in this
position and the simple reason is White
has this lethal response Bishop to b6 so
that if the King moves then black will
lose a piece and the obvious response F
captures c6 completely fails due to the
simple tactic Queen captures a6 check
King to d8 and now Knight grab 7 check
forces black to give up the Queen and in
fact the game
the second option Bishop to e7
in fact I played in the game so black
has still the threat on s2 but see
yourself how quickly white get the upper
hand with Bishop captures f7 check so
already I have to be careful King has to
go to the only Square King to d7 and I
had some hope in this position thinking
that okay I'm attacking his Knight as
well as there's a threat of less true
but just one more and all of my hopes
are gone my opponent played this
accurate response Queen to d3 check and
now I really don't want to play Bishop
to d6 as all of my threat will be gone
and King to see it is not in possibility
due to the Queen - f I check
finally I decided to play Quinn 2d6
thinking that at least Quinn will be
exchanged and I'll be an exchange job
but this is just a miserable position
for black camp as after the accurate
response Queen captures fi check King to
see seven and white can't take denied
but in fact he found the better
continuation namely Knight to e6 Jack
so now King to d7 or King to c8 you are
in the line of discover check so I
choose the worst one King to be six but
my opponents top all my King dance with
this final decisive blow Knight to e4
check and I simply resign in the view of
King to e6 and now this wonderful move
Knight to C Phi so that if my King comes
up to the board then he is getting
checkmated and the only hope for the
black is to give up the Queen which I
personally think is a hopeless as black
open King and loss of material are too
much to handle the white attacker
well after that 18 move miniature I
personally look out for this line in
detail and amazingly enough this
exchange sacrifice is very sound and
gives white a great attacking chances
for example if here black can block the
check with the Queen still he get worst
position and I'd like to show you a game
between 2000 plus rated opponent where
black continued 8 Queen to e5 counters
checking the White Queen but why calmly
continue with Knight captures f7 black
responds his force black has to capture
on e 2 and after Knight captures e 2
there is nothing better than rook to g8
at least trying to save the exchange
well white find the accurate sequence
Knight to d6 Jack Bishop captures d6
Bishop captures g8 and yes at this point
white is a clear point up but blacks
idea was he wants to play Bishop
captures s2 check and after King to
affirm still that 7 point is hanging and
you don't have time to protect this as
g3 will trap down this Bishop but black
has calculated all of this and after
Knight to f6 he thought that he had a
balanced position guess what the game
finished very quickly after this as
white played Bishop to e6
so now indeed black is going to lose a
pawn as he has to save his Bishop so
black continue with Bishop to c7 and yup
white can't take on a fire and remain
upon up but white found even stronger
reply namely Bishop to CH
after Knight to d7 Bishop captures b7
rook to d8 and Bishop captures c6 the
dust is clear and you can easily see
after all this forcing transaction white
emerge with a two-point advantage which
is in fact more than sufficient to win
the game ok let's look at the second
move Queen to d8 and here comes the
important memory marker guys apart from
Queen to c7 if you are put in place any
other Queen moves then after this
exchange sacrifice you really want to
play the move Knight to e5 why what is
wrong with Knight to g5
well black has now enough resources to
cover the D file and now no longer there
is pressure on the ab7 square so
remember don't play Knight to g5 the
correct response is Knight to e5 and
this time around the point is night to
defy by black doesn't walk here and the
simple reason is after Knight captures
d5 pawn captures defy and the move
Bishop to b5 Jack Black Knight can't
block that deadly diagonally so it is
very obvious that here black has to come
up with a better choices
well after studying all of these
variations the first opponent I faced he
indeed continued with Queen to d8 and
after my Knight to e5 he found the best
response namely Queen to d4 attacking to
spot so white responds his force white
has to play Queen to e2 and now white is
ready to give the discover chat so my
opponent block it with Bishop to e7
now as the black is ready to castle you
have to throw this important check
Bishop captures f7 and here it doesn't
matter wherever the King goes white next
response are very obvious for example in
the game my opponent played the moon
King to f8 I simply respond with Bishop
to b3 and now White has a simple plan
namely night to f7 and napping the rook
in fact my opponent immediately made a
mistake in this position by playing
Knight B to d7 which allows this simple
tactics night to f7 rook to g8 and now
the star mu Knight to g5 so now I have a
double threat Bishop captures g8 as well
as the important one like to e6 chat
which will lap the black queen
my opponent played the move Queen to e5
and here chess engine suggest that I
should Howard the Queen trade which
completely gives wide of winning
advantage however I found the simple
solution namely Knight to e6 Jack King
to e8 Queen captures Queen Knight
captures Queen and now the sting in the
tail
Knight to c7 Jack King to d7 Knight
captures eight and after rook captures
eight if you carefully look at this
position not only white obtained a
bishop pair but he has a clear pawn
advantage which with accurately again
usually favors the white camp last but
not least what happens after Queen to b4
well more or less same story as we are
going to deliver this exchange sacrifice
with rook captures fi and here if black
continues with he captures Fi
then after Knight to e5 again black is
having a huge difficulty as after the
simple line let's say Knight to d7 we
can first kick this Queen out with a
three and when the Queen moves we can
now safely capture on f7 which gives
black a huge problem after Knight to g5
after rook to H it and the Moody fall
black simply cannot castle due to Knight
to f7 and the obvious looking new at six
completely fails due to the following
tactics
Knight to have seven look - at seven and
now the star mu Bishop clear fall and
even though black is an exchanger he has
a complete miss coordination going on in
his cam and all in all this position
usually favor the white camp
so again after rue captors fi if black
dig the rook then he's asking for the
trouble but you might say hang on you
captured my bishop I will capture yours
and now on as doesn't your ruckus
completely misplaced well of course not
as White has this following line which
against gives him a great advantage here
the key mu you how to remember is d3
attacking the Queen and the best place
for the Queen is to go to the a6 square
and after that White has this small trap
starting with route where for in fact
one of my lower ranked opponent fall
into this as he continued with this
obvious looking move Bishop to d6
attacking my rogue but after the
following sequence rook to e4 counter
attacking the Queen Queen to b6 and now
did you spot it yup the easiest move
Bishop to e3
attacking the Queen and in the game my
opponent decided to play Queen to c7
which with the naked eye Vince the pawn
after rook captures a7 rook captures a7
and Bishop captures a7 and mind you this
Bishop is not trapped as after b6 we can
simply capture this knight and remain a
healthy pawn
advantage that's
guys I hope you enjoy like this
wonderful exchange sack in the
Scandinavian remember if you opponent
played the obvious looking moves see six
give him this rude shock with rook to e5
and it doesn't matter wherever the Queen
moves the next move is very obvious yup
this wonderful exchange sac which
enables white a great attack on f7
and however black wriggles the victory
awaits for you just within the opening
stage thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care